we're remembering the very influential
life of Hugh Hefner
he made his Network television debut in
1956 on CBS speaking to Mike Wallace
have to defended the image of Playboy
magazine sex always will be an important
part of the book because sex is probably
the single thing that men are most
interested in all of this I think that
you'll agree it's a sniggering kind of
sex it's a lascivious kind of sex it
certainly isn't a healthy approach to
sex we ingest that it is I would not
only suggest that I would say rather
strongly we considered a pretty healthy
man well by the 1970s playboy had more
than 7 million readers Wow and Hefner
was certainly a household name he built
an empire on the simple idea that sex is
important to people with us from Los
Angeles Matt is Matt Bellinis editorial
director of The Hollywood Reporter good
morning to you Matt good morning well he
certainly changed the magazine culture
he changed the American sex culture if
you will but that came with some
controversy back in the day there were a
lot of protests about how women were
portrayed in the magazine what are the
critics say today about the legacy that
he's left I think it's a very
complicated legacy because on the one
hand playboy was criticized it was the
first major mainstream magazine to
feature nude women and it was in the
context of politics and lifestyle and
all these other things but it was
essentially a naked women magazine and
you know people like Gloria Steinem at
the time very opposed said playboy could
fill a book with what it doesn't know
about women but on the other hand it was
filled with progressive politics and it
was the you know one of the few
magazines that they interviewed MLK and
they interviewed Muhammad Ali and they
did a lot of articles that were very
progressive in the politics they were
pro-choice at a time when not many
outlets were openly so and they were
very Pro First Amendment and these
causes that the culture sort of caught
up to but playboy was doing it at a time
in the in the 50s 60s 70s when it wasn't
that accepted from big national
magazines like that when I was growing
up there were two magazines you
collected one was Playboy and the other
was a National Geographic
very different Matt what happens going
forward we know that his son Cooper is
going to be taking over the magazine the
circulation has dropped significantly as
have many industry magazines as well how
does the magazine and the brand go
forward in a digital age it's a tough
road we recently Cooper Hefner Hughes
son has assumed control of the brand but
the magazine you know they have gone
through a rocky tenure with multiple
editors they got rid of nude pictures
then they brought them back they have a
very lucrative licensing business where
the playboy brand is very meaningful
around the world but in the u.s. they
really have struggled and the culture
has sort of gone beyond Playboy they
have to figure out a way to make the
playboy brand relevant in today's media
and cultural environment of course
everyone will remember that iconic
Playboy bunny founded right Matt thank
you so much thank you